يبدو ان ملف عملاق التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر لا يغيب عن عناوين الاخبار
الاسبوعيه فبعد ازمه الاستقالات والاقالات
التي عصفت بالعصفور الازرق ظهرت منذ فتره
قضيه الديون المترتبه على الشركات لكن
تويتر سددت اول دفعه فائده على ديون بقيمه
12.5 مليار دولار استخدمها ايلون ماسك
لجعل عملاق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي شركه
خاصه العمل الماضي حيث استعنت الشركه
بمجموعه من سبعه بنوك بقياده مورجان سالي
الذي علق الديون او علق بالديون بعد ان
عجز عن بيعها لمستثمرين خارجيين رغم ذلك
مشاهدينا يبدو ان فاتوره الديون بالنسبه
لتويتر لا تزال كبيره حيث من المتوقع ان
تتجاوز الفائده السنويه
1.2 مليار دولار ويحمل بعضها معدلات
متغيره من الفائده يمكن ان تستمر في
الزياده مع قيام الاحتياطيه الفيدراليه
الامريكي برفع اسعار الفائده